ينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل فرانس 2 ك مازن
عباس اهلا بك مازن من خلال تصريحات الكرل
امس واليوم هناك على ما يبدو يعني تصميم
على مواصله المعارك في اوكرانيا هل من
تفاصيل اوف او هل اتضحت ملامح الخطوط
العريضه ل المرحله المقبله عسكريا في
اوكرانيا يعني ما يتعلق بالوضع العسكري
وبحسب بيان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان
القوات الروسيه والدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
قد تمكنت من اسقاط مروحيه اوكرانيه مي 24
ونحو 32 مسيره اوكرانيه كانت موجهه لتدمير
اهداف معينه بالاضافه لاعتراض
قظف قذائف المدفعيه يمرس خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه ايضا احبطت القوات الروسيه بحسب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه خمس هجمات اوكرانيه
على محور كوبان السك وسببت خسائر بشريه
للقوات الاوكرانيه وايضا في المعدات حيث
تمت
الدبابه ومدافع هاوزر وكذلك ايضا تعاملت
القوات الروسيه مع هجمات على محور كرانس
نولي مانسك بالاضافه لذلك شنت القوات
الروسيه هجمات سواء بالمدفعيه و بالصواريخ
في دانيتسك وعلى محور زبروجيا وايضا سببت
للقوات الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره في المعدات
والارواح موسكو تعتبر
انها العمليه العسكريه مستمره وهذا ما جاء
في تصريحات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بالامس عندما اشار ان الغرب لم يتخلى عن
اهداف عن اهدافه التي وصفها بالعدوانيه في
اوكرانيا وان روسيا ايضا لم تتخلى عن
اهدافها في العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وستستمر العمليه العسكريه حتى تحقيق
الاهداف الروسيه بوتين كان قد اشار بالامس
وايضا اكد وزير دفاع سيرجي شويجو على ان
القوات الروسيه تسيطر على الوضع العسكري
وتنفذ العمليات التي تعتبرها ضروريه وفي
التوقيت المناسب وبحسب تصريحات سيرجي
شويجو ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد بلغت
خسائرها منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه
البشريه اكثر من 380 ال جندي وضابط
بالاضافه الى نحو 16000 اليه ومدرعه
ودبابه وا يعني خلال اجتماع مجلس وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه كان هناك تصريح واضح بان
القوات الروسيه تحقق انتصارات والتقدم
وستواصل العمليات العسكريه الى ان تسيطر
اولا على اراضي الاقاليم الاربعه التي
عمليا تم ضم الى روسيا وبالاضافه
الى يعني تجريد اوكرانيا من السلاح تصبح
دوله منزوعه السلاح كي لا تهدد الامن
القومي الروسي شكرا جزيلا لك مازل عباس مس
في موسكو